now some of the traffic in the rotunda
making their way
up the escalator for game two of the
doubleheader
it's been one hot day in new york and
the meds trying to get hot winning two
straight over the nationals 8-7
yesterday and the completion of the
suspended game 4-1 of the first game of
the doubleheader today field and trevor
williams brought over from the cubs and
the same deal that brought the met javi
baez will make his mets debut well the
toyota numbers for trevor williams you
can see the high era but coming off
maybe his best start of the year sixth
and a third scoreless
breaking ball line to center and comes
nimmo and makes the catch to retire the
sign so an easy inning for trevor
williams in his first downing as a met
penny who has really struggled lately
going for the nats you know those land
rover numbers though gary his first nine
starts
he was four and three with a 2.54
but as you talked about his last eight
with a 7.75
line the other way and pete's got
himself a base hit and that'll go back
to the corner soto plays the karen pete
trying for two and soto's throw will be
too late
an opposite field double for alonso his
first hit of the day
oh two in the 90 fastball upstairs
eric fetty and now it's ryan zimmerman
who sets a new nat's record by simply
stepping on the field
that's line to left dom smith going back
and he made the catch oh wow
that ball appeared to beat dumb over his
head but he made up ground and retires
andrew stevenson
beautifully done by dom
hard first out that ball was hit right
on the nose by stevenson had some carry
on it
and just a little well-timed half leap
there by dom
just gets him to the apex to catch that
line drive from stevenson applauded by
trevor
conforto drives one deep center field
back goes robles looking up and it's one
hop against the wall
and conforto pulls into second base with
a well-struck double
and davis lines a base hit to right
center and the mets will take the lead
it goes all the way to the wall conforto
is in davis replaces him at second base
back to back doubles to start at the
bottom of the fourth and the meds lead
in one nothing
that's lined to center field falling
fast
jd have to hold up he'll go to third and
stop there
three straight hits for the mets to
start this bottom of the fourth vr now
two for two
ken struck out his first time up
and he grounds one past the mound behind
the back sanchez with the flip the throw
by
by uh garcia is awry
no advance but a run comes home
on the fielder's choice davis scores to
make it two nothing
and he grounds this one on the right
side sanchez has it and that retires the
side but the mets score two
davis with the go ahead hit two nothing
mets after four
that ball is ripped into left center
over to get it smith sanchez rounding
the bag and heading for two
in there
great swing by adrian sanchez his fifth
base hit of the year
and this one out to right center will
fall
sanchez held up for a moment he stops at
third
bottom of the order making something
happen here okay
and eric fetty will be done for the day
yadiel hernandez about to hit first
things first try to get one across here
and that's pretty well hit to left
gonna back up dominic smith
sanchez will score easily
now can the other runner make it to
second nope pereira's gonna retreat
he threw it into the right base
just like that the nets are on the board
and conforto grounds one toward the
middle of the diamond sanchez can't get
it and confort has got himself another
hit this one not hard hit just well
placed
fourth hit of the double header for
conforto
here's vr who's two for two in this game
the r slams one to deep center field
back goes roll blast to the warning
track at the wall and it's off the wall
or is it out of here it is out of here a
2-1 homer for vr
and the mets extend their lead to 4-1
it's been the best insurance policy
they've had in quite some time watch the
catcher here and roblox knew it and saw
that it hit the black and
not the blue
and that's all it takes to be a home run
up the middle to his left is garcia
throwing from the sit spin and he can't
get it on target and mccann has an
infield hit
one two coming and nemo drives one out
to center robles
is there and that retires the side but
the two run homer by vr gives the med
some space
garcia rips one got a fastball up
conforto to us left to pick it up
now the nats need another knock to get
that tying run in the box
high fastball little tweener at short
long throw and the ball gets away from
pete alonso
garcia checks in at second
and how about this the nats will get the
tying run into the box and
pete alonso telling his teammates i
probably should have had that robles on
deck one out here it comes
and he misses with the fastball
the bases are loaded with one oh that's
a good idea
and that is right through the wickets
here comes garcia
4-2 ball game
and stevenson right side it is through
scoring is sanchez
para home
andrew stevenson has shocked the mints
and tied this game
that was awesome
on the outside corner he got him looking
zimmerman strikes out for the third time
in this game but the nats rally for
three runs to tie it mcneal and alonso
will come up in the bottom of the
seventh trying to win it so now one out
and here's alonzo beats two for three in
this game
2-0 coming
and alonso hits a high-fly ball to left
back goes stevenson to the warning track
at the wall and
it's out of here
lonzo wins it with a towering walk-off
home run
that home run won't reign and it brings
the men to sweep for the double header
and the three-game series
number 25 for alonso and the mets pull
off their ninth walk-off win of the year
alonso goes deep the jersey comes off
and the mets win it 5-4